une assemblée générale réunissant des
producteurs d'ananas louis daniel berten
y est invité occasion pour le président
de la chambre d'agriculture de les
écouter pour si besoin relayer les
doléances de la profession la
coopérative sca ananas compte également
des maraîchers des producteurs de
légumes racines concernés par la
chlordécone
elle fait débat dans la profession
depuis une quinzaine d'années 'l'annonce
d'une filière encerclant déconne
interroge la chambre d'agriculture
car elle stigmatise selon elle tous les
autres ceux qui ont des résidus de
chlordécone dans leur sol gis les
limites ne sont pas bonnes mais il faut
les changer mais une fois qu'on a qu'on
a mis en place des limites de résidus
ben épaules les agriculteurs sont
chargés de les respecter et les césars
ginter respecter les métaux et donc je
pense que c'est pas en attaquant des
agriculteurs des solutions s'il faut
attaquer les limites ont il faut les
attaquer mais il faut pas stigmatiser la
production agricole
une filière 0 chlordécone annoncé en
grande pompe par le parc naturel
régional
oui mais ce serait ignorer le travail
fait par la chambre travail fait
toujours selon l'instance depuis des
années maintenant place à une sorte de
filet comme ça je ne sais pas à quoi ça
sert je ne sais pas qui
est-ce que ça va servir à quelque chose
on a déjà une filière au chlordécone qui
est la nature de la culture biologique
bon
salez les auditions en toute logique ils
garantissent c'est au cloud écoles on a
également un travail qui est fait avec
l'ensemble des producteurs qui mettent
en place des cultures dites sensibles à
la claude école de ski et à sin tout ce
qui est produits qui sont sur le sol
comme tout ça il espère que cette
respectent la réglementation et il
respecte les colonisations qu'on leur
fait une filière 0 chlordécone ces
agriculteurs n'y sont pas opposés au
contraire tous ont subi des contrôles
mais vont-ils y adhérer tout ce que je
plante je mange je ne peux pas planter
quelque chose un point jaune et mes
plantations
moi je vous sais pas une marque de
confiance d'avoir un label g par rapport
au projet pour votre quantité sur le
département qui ne subissent pas les
mêmes contrôles que nous on nous demande
alors pour moi je disais je veux dire
avant il fallait regarder ce qui arrive
l'année portée avant de se retourner sur
les marchés
les producteurs maternité et la chambre
d'agriculture y est elle opposée
l'action du parc naturel peut-elle se
combiner avec celle de la chambre
vont-ils travailler ensemble le parc
naturel c'est pas simple c'est pas sa
mission première de travailler sur sur
le monde agricole sur le développement
agricole
donc je crois qu'il faut que chacun
reste dans ses prérogatives et les
choses seront bien sûr mais fait la
chambre d'agriculture la veille avec un
cercle de partenaires agricoles des
coopératives notamment des ou dvd
beaucoup de conducteurs des syndicats
agricoles louis daniel berten compte
réunir tous ses partenaires mardi pour
discuter de cette problématique et de
cette nouvelle filière qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité chez les agriculteurs